so yesterday Donald Trump went on this
wild totally unhinged Twitter rant which
Bendixon told you about I was traveling
down to New Orleans yesterday for
Netroots nation I'm here in New Orleans
and I'll be telling you about some of
what's going on here as well and we're
now learning a little bit about what
triggered the Twitter frenzy which
included calling for Attorney General
Jeff Sessions to just end the robert
muller investigation into trump russia
altogether and we've heard before a
collusion is not a crime we've heard it
time and again in the last year and yet
the actual crimes like obstruction of
justice
seem more and more likely by the day and
what we've now learned according to ABC
News based on sources close to the White
House is that special prosecutor Robert
Muller who of course is in charge of
this Trump Russia investigation wants to
ask President Donald Trump specifically
about obstruction of justice and this is
big for a couple different reasons it's
not news that Moeller wants to talk to
Trump we've been talking about that for
a while it's not news that Trump's
lawyers don't want Trump to talk to
Muller we've been able to to ascertain
that because people like Rudy Giuliani
has straight-up said it we don't want
Trump to talk to Robert Muller and we've
sort of been able to guess what Robert
Muller would want to talk about but the
big news now which reportedly Trump
learned about in the last 24 to 48 hours
during that Twitter frenzy is that
Robert Muller on the one hand is willing
to limit the scope of the questioning to
a degree and that's been a huge point of
contention Trump's lawyers don't want
Trump going in there and being able to
be asked about everything or close to
everything they want a predetermined
list of subjects which they can prepare
Donald Trump for to the extent that the
guy can prepare for anything and one of
the topics under discussion for those
limitations is indeed obstruction of
justice so this is huge for a couple of
different reasons
number one it's huge because it's been a
little bit of radio silence for the last
few weeks or month and a half about
whether or not Trump and Moeller are
actually going to talk and this of
course confirms that that conversation
is still ongoing but it also
confirms that whether Trump committed
crimes is a focus of the investigation
and we also now know that Trump knows
this Trump for a very long time has been
insisting I'm not under investigation
James Comey told me I'm not under
investigation is Trump a target or a
subject or a person of interest what we
now know and you can apply whatever
legal language you want to it is that
Robert Muller wants to ask Trump about
questions relating to the crime of
obstruction of justice and Trump as you
know from yesterday again because Ben
Dixon told you this went on this wild
Twitter rant which I won't repeat to you
in total but I do want to remind you
about one particular tweet that was part
of that which is when Donald Trump
tweeted this is a terrible situation and
Attorney General Jeff Sessions should
stop this rigged witch-hunt right now
before it continues to stain our country
any further
Bob Muller is totally conflicted and his
seventeen angry Democrats that are doing
his dirty work are a disgrace to the
United States so first of all the scale
up of the smear campaign against robert
muller
coincides with the progress of these
negotiations around trump being
interviewed by muller and bigger picture
we see these Trump Twitter rants and it
sometimes appears randomly timed right
like the 4:00 a.m. rant about who knows
what but we learn in example after
example after example that what really
is true is that they are real-time
reactions to whatever happens to be
angering Donald Trump at the time and
sometimes we don't find out about it
until later this is one case Trump goes
on this rant it's not exactly clear why
we later learn this was happening almost
in real time as he was told
Moeller wants to talk to you about
obstruction of justice
now in terms of the strategy because it
might seem dumb or ignorant or
ill-informed ill-advised to learn that a
special prosecutor wants to ask you
about obstruction of justice and then
you go on Twitter and you do what is
arguably
trying to obstruct that justice which is
directing your Attorney General to end
the investigation into obstruction of
justice is Trump dumb or is he so I
guess a narcissistic is the word that
when he finds out molar wants to talk
about obstruction of justice he goes on
Twitter and tries to obstruct that
investigation by tweeting that it should
end I don't know the answer and I'm
curious whether the committed Trump is
now ready to say I'm not even asking for
a big concession but is the committed
Trump is ready to say okay Muller is
looking into whether Trump committed
crimes it's it's not proof that Trump
did anything wrong it's only an
indication that Moeller is looking at
possible criminal action by Donald Trump
at the minimum obstruction of justice
and then of course there's questions of
witness tampering money laundering
financial crimes and all of this other
stuff and forget about now knowing that
molar wants to explore of strong
obstruction
is this how an innocent person acts
right forget about the question of will
we ultimately determine that crimes were
committed can a president be indicted
those are separate questions
is this how an innocent person acts
Muller still wants to talk including
about obstruction and Trump says end the
entire thing right now
the fear is obvious the panic is very
transparent and my hope is that soon
we'll have a final determination about
is the sit-down going to take place what
limitations are being placed on Robert
Muller or his investigators who maybe
would be as likely to be speaking to
Donald Trump I'm hoping that we get
confirmation about this really soon
because it's abundantly clear that
you've got to talk to Trump now Trump is
connected enough to this that even
though Trump's lawyers for months have
been trying to prevent this sit-down
between Moeller's team and Donald Trump
Muller is not going away we don't yet
have reason to believe a subpoena has
been issued but that's always been in
the background this is clearly an
investigation that can't be satisfied in
a satisfactory way unless Donald Trump
is personally interviewed and that is
increasingly clear and hopefully we'll
have news soon about
if and when that conversation is going
to take place